je suis musicienne pourtant à deux
reprises j'ai essayé d'arrêter le violon
à 15 ans je faisais un peu de la musique
parce que mes parents l'avaient décidé
je me suis arrêté trois mois trois mois
pour comprendre que je voulais vraiment
poursuivre que c'était ma vocation que
c'était une nécessité à 30 ans j'avais
un enfant j'étais mariée et j'avais
beaucoup de mal à faire face au stress
et au rythme de vie j'ai arrêté les
concerts plus d'un an
au début ça a été un soulagement
et puis j'ai ressenti un manque et très
vite j'ai l'impression que je pouvais
plus respirer que j'ai tout fait comme
si j'avais un sac plastique sur la tête
encore aujourd'hui il m'arrive de rêver
à une vie normale
je sais que c'est pas possible la
musique accompagne tous mes mots en
dépit de doutes de joie de tristesse de
bonheur
c'est comme une bulle qui me permet de
voyager qui permet de sortir du
quotidien et qui me relie à quelque
chose de beaucoup plus grand la musique
donne sens à ma vie
elle donne sens à la vie
ma pratique instrumentale je la mets au
service d'un compositeur j'approche
chaque oeuvre avec tout ce que je sais
mais surtout tout ce que je suis et
petit à petit l'oeuvre se révèle c'est
comme si j'ai établi un lien entre un
compositeur qui est mort depuis très
très longtemps pour la plupart du temps
son oeuvre est le public qui écoutent
aujourd'hui je suis un peu passeur de
musique ce lien nous lis dans l'espace
et dans le temps et en ça nous fait à
toucher à quelque chose d'essentiel
cette pratique instrumentale ne peut se
faire que si je suis pleinement ancré en
moi dans l'instant présent libre de ce
que je suis pour pouvoir me tourner vers
l'oeuvre la comprendre et la partager
cette façon d'être est essentielle en
musique mais elle peut devenir une
philosophie c'est un peu ma philosophie
de vie ancré dans le présent dans
l'instant présent libre de ce que je
suis pour me tourner au mieux vers
l'autre et tenter de comprendre un peu
le monde
cet accès au monde
j'ai envie de partager je trouve que
c'est un peu ma légitimité à moi
musicienne à nouveau musicien mais cette
musique dite classique est ce qu'elle
est accessible à tous à tout moment
n'importe où un test a été fait aux
états unis yoshi abel qui est un très
grand violoniste qui joue un des plus
bel instrument au monde un stradivarius
accepté de jouer à neuf heures du matin
dans le métro de washington
la vidéo vous avez peut-être vu est
impressionnante
les gens continuent à courir personne ne
lève les yeux
la veille il jouait devant mille
personnes pour certaines personnes
avaient payé jusqu'à 100 dollars leur
place le lendemain la même personne dans
le métro a récolté 34 dollars en 45
minutes dont 20 par la seule personne
qu'il a reconnue ce que cela nous dit
c'est quand d'où cette dent ou quand
nous sommes dans cette course dans cette
agitation intérieure que l'on connaît
tous nous ne sommes pas disponibles nous
ne pouvons percevoir la beauté vous
arrêter pour l'apprécier reconnaître le
talent la musique parce qu'elles se
déroulent dans le temps nécessite de
s'apaiser de se mettre en éveil au
concert petit à petit le coup le silence
se fait le vrai science le silence qui
rend disponible celui que nous vivons
actuellement et qui nous relient
ce sont des moments de communion
palpable la différence c'est que je vous
parle je fais passer j'essaye un message
est bien ce qui est merveilleux en
musique c'est qu'il ya pas un message
chacun peut partir dans son univers
faire son voyage se raconter son
histoire
alors ces moments de partage
j'ai toujours envie de les vivre avec un
plus grand nombre parce que je ne pense
pas que la musique soit élitiste je
pense qu'elle est accessible à tous il
suffit de s'apaiser de se rendre
disponible de se faire ce silence
intérieur qui rend disponible à la
beauté à la musique mais c'est le même
silence qui rend disponible à la
connaissance à l'amitié à l'amour à la
vie
ramzi abou redwan est un jeune
palestinien à 7 ans il participe à la
première intifada il voit mourir une
grande partie de sa famille loin d'avoir
peur il nourrit une soif de vengeance
à 17 ans il rencontre un musicien
jordanien qui lui propose d'apprendre
l'alto plus tôt c'est un peu comme le
violon c'est pas très facile et pourtant
il accepte mais il est persuadé qu'il
arrêtera au bout d'un mois
parce que cette pratique est élitiste et
surtout elle est tellement loin de ces
préoccupations quotidiennes
pourtant à l'issue des master class il
désire poursuivre il a découvert le
moyen de fuir occupation et comme
réfugiés la musique lui permet de passer
les barrières les frontières les murs il
décide de poursuivre sa formation en
france et aux états unis
sept ans après il revient à ramallah et
là il a un choc a en france
les murs des écoles sont tapissés de
dessins de princesse le prince charmant
de maisons de fleurs d'arbres et bien
ramallah les murs sont tapissés de chars
de mitrailleuses deux kamikazes et ramzy
réalise à quel point la musique a
transformé sa façon de voir le monde
alors il va jouer dans les écoles et là
encore une fois la vidéo est
impressionnante
parce que très vite les murs sont
tapissés de notes de musique et
d'instruments de musique
et il réalise à quel point il est
possible de modeler l'esprit d'un enfant
d'un être humain changer sa conscience
aujourd'hui
ramzi abou redwan nous dit des pierres
au violon c'est le même combat que je
mène
on peut détruire une maison ériger un
mur on ne peut pas vous voler votre âme
votre identité
il dit aussi le monde du son est capable
de hisser d'individus de l'inquiétude
pour sa propre existence à une
perception universel de sa place parmi
les êtres humains j'ai toujours eu envie
et j'ai toujours je suis toujours allé
jouer dans des lieux qui ne sont pas
consacré à la musique classique alors
dans le milieu on appelle ça allait vers
les nouveaux publics
moi je vais vers le public il y as en
2000 âgés initié avec des amis une série
de musique de chambre à trappes en
yvelines
c'est une banlieue difficile dit
difficile de la banlieue parisienne
soyons très honnête
pendant plusieurs années nous avons
toucher entre 20 et 50 personnes au
concert essentiellement composé de nos
amis je les remercie et de quelques
mélomanes
heureusement dès le début il ya eu ces
moments avec les enfants
cette jeune fille noire à l'issue d'un
concert qui nous demande de lui parler
du piano des touches blanches des
touches noires
alors on essaye de lui expliquer les
deux mythes ont la gamme en lui joue
rien n'est fait alors d'elle-même elle
vient sur scène les fleurs une touche
blanche
elle écoute une touche noir nous dit
vous voulez dire ya aucune différence où
cet enfant de deux ans lors d'un concert
pour des jeunes filles mères cet enfant
de deux ans qui signifie clairement à sa
maman qui veut quitter en plein milieu
de l'oeuvre le concert que lui veut
rester et bien l'enfant est resté sur
les genoux d'une autre maman mais ce qui
est beau c'est que trois jours plus tard
il y avait un concert officiel et dans
la salle il y avait la jeune maman au
premier rang elle est juste devenue une
une beau voir avec les amis et me dire
qu'elle s'était éclatées et puis à ces
moments à saint-quentin-en-yvelines des
concerts en france n qui réunissent un
orchestre professionnel et un choeur qui
travaillent toute l'année qui regroupe
des enfants des quartiers de drap en
yvelines quand j'ai fait ce concert et
que j'ai vu la levée de rideau le lever
de rideau où pendent tous ces enfants
chanter ensemble le coeur de carmen
alors que quelques instants avant ont
vérifié qu'ils n'avaient rien dangereux
dans les poches
c'était quelque chose de fort pourtant
je vais être très franche quand j'ai
traversé trappe à pied un samedi après
midi pour aller de la gare à la salle de
concert je me suis dit que ce que je
faisais n'avait aucun sens c'était
certainement le fruit d'une pensée
généreuse mais c'était aussi le fruit
d'une pensée prétentieuse de quelqu'un
de très plus les comment pouvais-je
prétendent mois à porter la musique soit
disant vital à des gens qui eux avaient
de réelles préoccupations vitales se
loger et manger
heureusement soir-là au premier rang il
y avait une jeune femme noire et ses
trois enfants qui est venu pour à la fin
du concert qui m'a simplement dit
remercier en me disant que ces moments
on faisait désormais partie de sa vie où
cette femme seule qui me dit attendre le
prochain concert et qui me dit qu il
m'écrit c'est de ce souffle dont j'ai
besoin pour respirer
ce sont des mots qui me parlent qui me
touchent aujourd'hui la salle est comble
plus de dix ans tout récemment nous
avons joué devant nous avons donné des
concerts scolaires devant des enfants
1500 enfants entre 7 et 10 ans des
quartiers trappe
au programme c'était le deegan de ravel
alors le dit gagnent de ravel c'est pas
vraiment une oeuvre très accessible à
priori en général dans ce genre de
concert on présente plus tôt pierre et
le loup
le carnaval des animaux ou les quatre
saisons du gr10 donc c'est un peu un
défi
on essaye donc de présenter lors
qu'istres expliqué les sources
d'inspiration et puis on a prévu de
jouer tout le digg and faut savoir que
ledit gagnent commence par une cadence
pour violon seul de cinq minutes
alors vous pouvez imaginer ce que c'est
pour un enfant de 7 ans qui n'a jamais
entendu une musique d'écouté un violon
seul pendant cinq minutes
d'ailleurs le chef d'orchestre y croit
pas du tout et il me dit marianne je te
conseille de couper la cadence bon ça
m'ennuie un peu je me dis je vais
essayer au moins la première séance je
me donne quelque chance je donne des
clés d'écouté comme des petites valises
dans une balade alors vous allez
rencontrer l'alouette et là il va se
passer telle chose et le violon va
monter les glao et je me lance je pense
jamais avoir entendu un tel silence le
silence intérieur de 500 enfants et le
plus beau silence
je n'ai jamais vécu c'est un cadeau qui
m'ont fait que nous avons partagés ce
sont ces moments qui donne un vrai sens
à ma vie d'artiste
le lendemain au concert officiel
nous avons une offre nombreuses
réservations nouvelle parce que les
enfants qui étaient venus la veille
avait réussi à convaincre leurs mamans
leurs frères leurs soeurs de pousser la
porte du concert officiel est de venir
écouter dans la salle de nombreuses
femmes étaient voilées dans ces moments
ce sont ces moments qui comptent pour
moi je me sens en passeur de quelque
chose de plus permanent que la vie
passeurs de lumière je l'espère
la musique mais vitale c'est comme une
bulle qui me permet de voyager ensemble
la vie sans musique est tout simplement
une erreur
et
m
e
coli
m
nous